steigende infektionszahlen in frankreich
die bundesregierung waren vor reisen
nach paris und an die côte d'azur streit
um corona tests die gesundheitsminister
wollen sie für urlaubsrückkehrer
einschränken bayerns ministerpräsident
widerspricht und proteste in west
konzernabschlüssen auf einen schwarzen
kommt es zu schweren ausschreitungen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg und nand und willkommen
schön dass sie dabei sind wie auch
norbert lehmann für den sport deutsche
wunder an der familie wir beginnen mit
der krone situation in frankreich denn
die ist mittlerweile wieder so
besorgniserregend dass die
bundesregierung eine reisewarnung
ausgesprochen hat für den großraum paris
und für die côte d'azur
aktuell steigen in frankreich die neue
infektionen rasant in der vergangenen
woche infizierten sich etwas 25.000
menschen mit dem virus für die deutsche
reisewarnung war entscheidend dass in
der hauptstadt und in teilen der
französischen mittelmeerküste der sieben
tage schnitt die kritische grenze von 50
neuinfektionen pro 100.000 einwohnern
überschritten hat christel hass
berichtet strandurlaub in nizza oder in
marseille sightseeing in paris für
deutsche ist dass ab sofort nicht mehr
empfohlen
alle die jetzt dort sind müssen sich bei
der heimkehr testen lassen oder ein
negatives ergebnis vorweisen
ich glaube das ist angemessen und wir
werden jetzt nach der rückkehr einen
test machen in hamburg am flughafen und
hoffen natürlich dass der test negativ
ist die reisewarnung hat viele
überrascht selbst die
bundesjustizministerin zu gesprächen in
paris war nicht informiert
ich war nicht darauf vorbereitet aber
jetzt werden wir alle notwendigen
konsequenzen dann auch daraus ziehen
in frankreich sind die infektionen
drastisch angestiegen betroffen sind vor
allem jüngere die oft keine symptome
zeigen in paris und anderen städten gilt
deshalb teilweise auch auf der straße
masken pflicht die zahl der
ausländischen touristen ist ohnehin
gering dass jetzt wohl auch die
deutschen gäste wegbleiben ist ein
weiterer tiefschlag für die korona
gebeutelte branche
es ist ungerecht wir haben doch sowieso
schon so wenige touristen aus
deutschland und aus europa frankreich
ist einer der wichtigsten handelspartner
von deutschland die reisewarnung jetzt
sehen die unternehmen dies und jenseits
des rheins aber dennoch gelassen
die ganze industrie standorte und so
weiter sind unserer ansicht nach jetzt
kurzfristig nicht betroffen von daher
rechnen mit keinen einschränkungen oder
mit irgendwelchen signifikanten
veränderungen die französische regierung
rechnet nicht damit dass die korona
zahlen schnell wieder sinken im
gegenteil die reisewarnung durfte also
länger bestand haben
wer aus dem urlaub heimkehrt kann sich
bislang kostenlos auf corona testen
lassen wer aus risikogebieten wie paris
kommt hat sogar die pflicht dazu
doch die gesundheitsminister von bund
und ländern wollen zumindest die gratis
tests wieder abschaffen
auch damit mehr tests zum beispiel für
pflegepersonal zur verfügung stehen
gegen die pläne gibt es allerdings
heftigen widerstand an sein stamm hat
die details
urlaub und virus das große thema ist
wird immer mehr zum politischen
streitthema
die gesundheitsminister wollen die
vielen tausend tests an flughäfen und
raststätten deutlich reduzieren
bayern lehnt diese pläne heute komplett
ab sie sei nicht durchdacht bayern will
das nicht sagt markus söder wir haben
innerhalb von wenigen wochen alles
stemmen müssen dann heißt es wieder
kommando zurück ich kann den sinn da
nicht erkennen der ihren herbstferien
gibt es auch die anstehen also von daher
halte ich es für notwendig auch hier
weiter zu testen vor allem für
diejenigen die aus risikogebieten aus
dem urlaub zurückkommen für diese risiko
rückkehrer gilt aktuell nur wer einen
negativen test vorweisen kann muss nicht
in quarantäne
der neue vorschlag wer nach der
sommerreisewelle aus risikogebieten
kommt muss auf jeden fall in sofort
quarantäne mindestens fünf tage erst
dann gibt es einen test eine begründung
diese zahl mehr als 800 75.000 corona
tests werden mittlerweile pro woche in
den laboren abgegeben etwa hier in
ingelheim am rhein
diese situation mit dem mit den vielen
tests für reis rückkehrer die hat eben
dazu geführt dass das vorher relativ
stabile proben volumen so auf 80 prozent
der test kapazitäten sich dann einfach
noch mal erhöht hat und jetzt dann dazu
führt dass wir schon unsere an unserem
leistungslimit arbeiten entlastung
bringen soll der plan der
gesundheitsminister weniger tests mehr
quarantäne
aber wer soll die eigentlich wie
kontrollieren nur eine von vielen
offenen fragen beim so schwierigen thema
virus und urlaub
ein blick auf die aktuelle corona lage
zeigt die zahl der neuinfektionen
hierzulande ist leicht zurückgegangen im
durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich 1350 menschen pro tag neu mit
dem virus angesteckt gestern lag der
schnitt bei 1.360 wie sehr die
wirtschaftsleistung unter der korona
krise leidet zeigen neue zahlen vom
bruttoinlandsprodukt zwischen april und
juni ist es deutlich eingebrochen um 9,7
prozent gegenüber dem ersten vierteljahr
so stark wie noch nie seit beginn der
berechnungen 1970 volkswirte gehen
allerdings davon aus dass die konjunktur
im zweiten halbjahr wieder fahrt
aufnimmt
viele firmen haben in der korona zeit
keine mitarbeiter entlassen müssen weil
sie sie in kurzarbeit schicken konnten
zur stunde berät der koalitionsausschuss
in berlin darüber dieses
kurzarbeitergeld zu verlängern und zwar
bis märz 2022
das ist teuer einige experten halten es
auch für falsch
was ist für die unternehmen bedeutet
zeigt dominique lars mester bei widrigen
wiesbaden bauen sie unter anderem
systeme zur geschwindigkeitsüberwachung
die blitzer konnten durch corona nicht
ausgeliefert werden lieferketten waren
unterbrochen 150 beschäftigte mussten in
kurzarbeit aktuell sind es nur noch 40
für uns hat es natürlich sehr stark sehr
positiver einfluss dass wir mitarbeiter
halten konnten dass wir uns
wirtschaftlich etwas entspannen konnten
und das wir natürlich unsere auslastung
auch an den bedarf orientieren konnten
und dadurch hat uns die kurzarbeit enorm
viel gebracht bisher wird
kurzarbeitergeld ein jahr lang gezahlt
im grundsatz sind sich union und spd
einig über eine verlängerung wir wollen
es auf 24 monate verlängern wir wollen
die vereinfachten den vereinfachten
bezug und vor allen dingen auch den
höheren das höhere kurzarbeits geld was
wir im rahmen des konjunkturpakets
beschlossen haben fortsetzen kritiker
sagen ein verlängertes kurzarbeitergeld
verdeckt die probleme arbeitslosigkeit
und notwendige veränderungen würden nur
aufgeschoben befürworter dagegen halten
den finanziellen aufwand für vertretbar
wenn man sich überlegt dass ein
unternehmen die lufthansa fast zehn
milliarden bekommt das andere
unternehmen sehr viel geld auch bekommen
dann sind das 15 milliarden euro die
sehr gut investiert sind denn je besser
es gelingt die beschäftigung zu
stabilisieren desto schneller kann sich
die wirtschaft nach der krise auch
erholen
bei wie drohen ick wollen sie die
mitarbeiter halten jetzt wo es wieder
anzieht sind sie froh dass mit der
kurzarbeit alle noch an bord sind andere
sehr viel umstrittenes thema im
koalitionsausschuss heute die
wahlrechtsreform seit jahren überfällig
weil das parlament immer größer wird
worum es geht zeigt markus twickler der
deutsche bundestag 598 abgeordnete solle
haben derzeit sind es 779 viele
wahlkreise gewinnt andere parteien
bekommen dafür ausgleichsmandaten damit
das wahlergebnis nicht verzerrt wird
und so könnten es weniger abgeordnete
werden keine überhangmandate mehr
dann hätten einige wahlkreise aber
keinen eigenen abgeordneten oder keine
ausgleichsmandaten mehr
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat diesen
vorschlag aber bereit seine absage
erteilt oder die wahlkreise verringern
von aktuell 2 199
doch ob das bis zur wahl im nächsten
jahr noch machbar ist ist fraglich
wenn es keine einigung gibt könnte der
bundestag dann also noch größer werden
nachfragen wir theo koll unseren
hauptstadtkorrespondenten wie groß ist
die chance dass sich die
koalitionspartner rechtzeitig
zusammenraufen
die chance ist leider sehr bescheiden
auch wenn wir von ihnen hören dass die
stimmung bisher freundlich und nüchtern
sein soll es geht bei diesem sperrigen
thema ja schlicht um die künftige
verteilung von macht und deshalb bewegt
sich seit mittlerweile sieben jahren
einfach nicht nur der bundestag der wirt
zwischenzeitig immer größer immer teurer
und durch die größe immer weniger
arbeitsfähig wolfgang schäuble hat schon
eine genehmigung für container
beantragen lassen je nachdem wie man das
wahlgesetz ändert hat entweder die eine
oder die andere seite einen vorteil und
das ist natürlich die perfekte
voraussetzung für politischen stillstand
weltweit hat nur das milliarden- folgt
die chinesen ein noch größeres parlament
als deutschland wenn man sich hier heute
also nicht einig dann dürften wir diesen
etwas bizarren rekord platz auch erst
einmal behalten
klare worte von theo koll herzlichen
dank zum fall des russischen
oppositionspolitikers navalny da hat
moskau die gift diagnose der berliner
ärzte mit den worten kommentiert wir
verstehen die eile der deutschen
kollegen nicht die mediziner an der
charité hatte gestern mitgeteilt dass
sie davon ausgehen dass navalny
vergiftet wurde
die eu fordert deshalb von russland
sofort unabhängig und transparent zu
ermitteln
der kreml weist die vorwürfe zurück auch
die deutschen ärzte könnten nicht sagen
was genau die symptome ausgelöst habe in
die usa dort starten auch die
republikaner in den wahlkampf und
entwerfen horror szenarien für den fall
eines sieges der demokraten
dann werde der sozialismus eingeführt
amerikaner wurden entwaffnet die polizei
mittellos kurz nur dort könne den
amerikanischen traum vor joe biden
retten
aus washington heike slansky
nun ist auch er offiziell der kandidat
nominiert ohne ernsthafte herausforderer
das ergebnis einstimmig
überraschungsbesuch in charlotte north
carolina
beim parteitag der republikaner trump
nutzt die bühne und warnt schon wieder
vor wahlbetrug
die einzige chance und diese wahl
wegzunehmen ist wenn die wahl
manipuliert ist wie werden diese wahl
gewinnen
seit monaten the tramp zweifel
bezeichnet die briefwahl als besonders
betrugsanfällig beweise liefert er nicht
die truck show die bei den demokraten
vergangene woche vor produzierte videos
die botschaft trump habe geliefert
versprechen gehalten die wirtschaft
handelsabkommen das militär redezeit für
seine treusten unterstützer mit scharfen
attacken sie warnen vor chaos und
anarchie
sollten die demokraten das weiße haus
zurück erobern
die demokraten werden euch die waffen
wegnehmen die gefängnisse lehrern euch
zu hause einsperren gangs einladen keine
polizei wir haben die wahl zwischen
kirche arbeit und schulen oder unruhen
plünderungen und vandalismus
düstere zeiten drohten bei trumps abwahl
so die botschaft der republikaner
vier tage parteikonvent eine aufholjagd
denn in den umfragen liegt trump derzeit
hinter seinem demokratischen
herausforderer beiden rassismus und
polizeigewalt ist ein riesenthema im us
wahlkampf angeheizt jetzt durch einen
neuen fall in wisconsin
dort wurde ein schwarzer amerikaner bei
einem polizeieinsatz offenbar mehrfach
in den rücken geschossen
vor den augen seiner kleinen kinder und
jetzt gibt es wieder proteste und
heftige ausschreitungen
peter jäger
vor allem in der nacht wird es gewaltsam
die demonstranten setzten autos in brand
attackieren geschäfte und
regierungseinrichtungen die polizei
antwortete mit tränengas
in der kleinstadt kinos wisconsin
eskaliert der protest nachdem er jacob
lake von der polizei niedergeschossen
wurde
wir wissen die unterstützung der leute
zu schätzen aber im namen von jakobs
eltern
wir bitten die leute friedlich zu
protestieren und nicht zu zerstören
wir wollen gerechtigkeit echte
gerechtigkeit am vergangenen sonntag
will der 29 jährige jacob lake offenbar
in sein auto einsteigen als ein polizist
ihm in den rücken schießt mindestens
siebenmal die umstände noch unklar
sechs kinder sitzen im wagen ihr vater
überlebt ist aber nach angaben seiner
familie querschnittsgelähmt das macht
keinen sinn jemanden so zu behandeln der
unbewaffnet ist denn nichts geworfen der
nicht geschlagen hat gegen rassismus
gegen polizeigewalt nachdem der afro
amerikaner george floyd ende mai durch
einen brutalen polizeieinsatz ums leben
kam nun ein offenbar neuer fall und neue
proteste
die zusage die ich der familie den
polizeibeamten und jedem hier gebe es
wird gerechtigkeit geben menschen werden
sich für ihre taten verantworten müssen
auch in anderen städten wie new york
ging die black lips matter bewegung
wieder auf die straße und will
klarmachen ihr anliegen muss eines der
bestimmenden themen im kampf um die
präsidentschaftswahl sein wenn man
telefonisch nicht weiterkommt hilft
vielleicht ein persönliches gespräch
so dachte wohl außenminister maß und
reißt er heute zuerst nach griechenland
und dann in die türkei um in einem
streit zu vermitteln der immer
gefährlicher wird
auslöser ist dieses türkische
forschungsschiff das begleitet von
kriegsschiffen im mittelmeer nach erdgas
sucht das erkundungsgebiet zwischen den
griechischen inseln kreta rhodos und
kastelorizo beansprucht aber athen für
sich die abgase
es ist der versuch zwei züge die
aufeinander zurasen noch zu stoppen
reisediplomatie des deutschen
außenministers zuerst den athen dann in
ankara und der appell an die
streitparteien zu verhandeln statt zu
provozieren ich höre dass an allen orten
dass die bereitschaft zum dialog besteht
und deshalb halten wir auch einen
solchen für erreichbar
letztlich eine verbindliche und
friedliche lösung über die streitfrage
im östlichen mittelmeer zu erzielen wird
dies nur möglich sein indem es direkte
gespräche zwischen der türkei und
griechenland gibt griechische und
türkische kriegsschiffe hielten heute
übungen in der umstrittenen zone im
mittelmeer ab der einsatz des türkischen
forschungsschiffes obertreis wurde
verlängert ankara zeigt sich
unnachgiebig erhebt ansprüche auf das
seegebiet vor seiner küste und entlang
seines festlandsockels am wochenende
noch hatte der türkische präsident den
europäern gedroht die türkische
entschlossenheit nicht zu unterschätzen
die türkei will die seegrenzen neu
verhandeln das aber lehnen die griechen
strikt ab und fordern harte sanktionen
bei seinem heutigen besuch ging es den
deutschen außenminister auch darum zeit
zu gewinnen noch in dieser woche könnten
die europäer sanktionen gegen ankara
beschließen diese aber erst mal nicht in
kraft setzen so willmann türken und
griechen an den verhandlungstisch
zwingen denn schon mehrfach in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten standen die
beiden nato-partner auch wegen des
gebiets streits im mittelmeer kurz vor
einem krieg von türkischer seite hieß es
man sei zu verhandlungen nicht aber zu
zugeständnissen bereit es gibt also noch
viel arbeit um diesen konflikt zu
entschärfen
da war ein kurzer viel schnee drinnen
das bitten wir zu entschuldigen
hierzulande stehen in einer woche die
tarifgespräche im öffentlichen dienst in
bund und kommunen an heute kam die
forderung der gewerkschaften verdi und
des beamtenbundes dbb
sie wollen 4,8 prozent mehr lohn für die
rund zwei millionen beschäftigten
die kommunalen arbeitgeber sagen wegen
der korona krise gebe es keinerlei
verteilungsspielraum und noch eine
positive nachricht aus der medizin seit
jahrzehnten versucht die welt die
kinderlähmung auszurotten jetzt ist sie
einen großen schritt weiter
in afrika sind die sogenannten polio
wild viren besiegt laut weko hat es auf
dem kontinent seit drei jahren keinen
vorfall mehr gegeben
nach dem trocknen ist damit eine zweite
viruserkrankung in afrika ausgerottet
polio gibt es nur noch in afghanistan
und pakistan jetzt zu dir norbert und zu
den neulingen ende fußball national und
ja drei frische gesichter die
bundestrainer jogi löw heute für die
spiele gegen spanien und die schweiz
benannt hat oliver baumann aus
hoffenheim florian neues aus gladbach
und senkrechtstarter rubin goossens von
atalanta bergamo
joachim löw bleibt sich auch nach zehn
monaten länderspielpause preusche rom
boateng und thomas müller sind trotz des
zweiten drittels mit den bayern weiter
keine option denn er ist sehr zufrieden
mit seinen jungen spielern
von daher gibt es für mich zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt keinen grund an dieser
ausrichtung an dieser vorstellung
irgendetwas zu verändern
sechs aktuelle nationalspieler werden
geschont in der nations league vier aus
münchen und zwei aus leipzig denn
nächstes jahr steht über allem daran
werde alle gemessen nach den kommenden
beiden länderspielen hat löw noch sechs
weitere in diesem jahr um mit allen
ausgiebig zu testen
beide länder spiele live bei uns im zdf
und ohne fans im stadion mit publikum
dagegen soll laut uefa der supercup
bayern münchen gegen den fc sevilla am
24 september in budapest stattfinden
von bis zu 20.000 zuschauern ist da die
liebe zum atp tennis turnier von
cincinnati das dieses jahr in new york
ausgetragen wird
und da hat deutschlands bester
tennisspieler die generalprobe für die
us open verpasst alexanders wäre ist
ausgeschieden
alexander zverev wird nachdenklich
während des spiels und auch danach
erstmals bereut er öffentlich seine
teilnahme an der umstrittenen adriá tour
in der korona pause vor publikum zu
spielen war vielleicht nicht das
schlauste aller zeiten aber gut es war
halt ein guter versucht irgendwie tennis
zurück zu bringen so ein bisschen wenn
wir die leute auch wieder was zum
schauen haben sportlich ist wäre es bei
seinem neustart noch ein stück von der
topform entfernt im match gegen den
früheren weltranglisten-ersten andy
murray gelingen ihm bei 11 doppelfehlern
nur selten so gut herausgespielte punkte
nach 32 6 und 6 2 3 aus sicht von 12
verwandelte den matchball zum 7 5 im
dritten satz
weitere spielpraxis gibt es für schweres
bis zum beginn der us open nun nicht
mehr
und die beginnen am montag nein da
bringt sturmtief kirsten morgen viel
wind und regen in den norden im süden
ist davon aber wohl wenig zu spüren die
details hat gleich katja horneffer im
heute journal um viertel vor zehn freut
sich christian sievers auf sie wir
freuen uns wenn sie morgen wieder dabei
sein wollen und wünschen ihnen noch
einen entspannten abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
die namen meine damen und herren da
kommt ein sturmtief zu uns und das ist
ein problem für die bäume die sind ja
noch voll belaubt und durch den
trockenstress geschädigt die werden also
morgen zum teil umkippen oder erste
werden ab gerupft werden dass mit dem
wind geht schon in der nacht los über
dem ärmelkanal morgen dann zunächst über
den ostfriesischen inseln und dann zieht
der wind über die mittelgebirge
ob das nun die eifel ist das sauerland
der thüringer wald oder das erzgebirge
und bis zum abend ist das sturmfeld aus
deutschland fast verschwunden dann
pfeift es allerdings noch an der nordsee
die kräftigsten windböen aber gibt es
morgen nachmittag und das eben vor allen
dingen in der mitte und auch in
norddeutschland da können dann durchaus
schwere sturmböen auftreten bis 100
kilometer pro stunde
aber auch in süddeutschland gibt es
stürmische windböen bis 70 kilometer pro
stunde
heute nacht fällt häufig regen in
norddeutschland sind auch einzelne
gewitter dabei im süden merken sie davon
gar nichts bei 19 bis zwölf grad morgens
in die regenfälle weiter nach osten der
wind dreht von süd west auf nordwest und
südlich des mains wird es von kilometer
zu kilometer sonniger im süden steigen
die temperaturen auf 21 bis 27 grad
unter den regenwolken sind es nur 17 bis
20 grad und wechselhaft geht es in den
nächsten tagen auch weiter schönen abend
noch